Timothy shalam is better looking than
Tom Holland oh man y yall going for the
sou oh oh y'all just pulling out lances
what is going on I'm going strongly
disagree on that Tom is the ultimate Riz
Master internet knows this Zena knows
this everyone knows this I love Tom's my
buddy so you you just I can't no no no
no no Tim I don't know I don't know
timot I don't know I think you got to go
you think I got to go what if I just do
this what if I just do this did we say
it's imperceptible how much I moov that
com yeah yeah yeah V on
that I think Timmy I think you've got
the classic look I think I love Tom paid
a lot of money for this look
man it's working brother it's working
cuz you're the
d
d straight
door good looking Department